-My next guest is
an Emmy-winning actress
who stars in the new show,
"Kevin Can F... Himself,"
which airs Sundays at 9:00 p.m
on AMC and is streaming on AMC+.
Please welcome Annie Murphy,
ladies and gentlemen!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪ -It's Annie Murphy ♪♪
♪♪ Actress of the day ♪♪
♪♪ She lacks the titles
you're not supposed to say ♪
♪♪ It's Annie Murphy ♪♪
♪♪ In sickness or in hell
♪♪ Married to Kevin
and he can eff himself ♪♪
♪♪ Yeah ♪♪
-They love you, come on.
I love you! We love you!
Annie, welcome back to the show.
-Thank you.
-And thanks for playing
"True Confessions" earlier
-Oh, it was a rush.
-It was.
This is the second time you've
been on our show, correct?
-Yes, yes.
-Technically, right?
-Technically, yes.
-The first time you were on,
you posted something
on Instagram
that I thought was funny.
You said, "If anyone wants
lessons in the art of bein
really chill and a generally
super cool dude,
just holler at me.
No refunds."
And this is you backstage
when I first met you.
And then here is you zoomed in
[ Laughter ]
-That was my first time
on the show.
But I was here as a guest of
Eugene and Catherine
years before.
-I remember this.
-And just to add to
the embarrassment of this,
my first time meeting you --
I hope you don't remember --
but Eugene and Catherine
were there and I was kind of
hiding out in the green room
and Catherine...
-I remember this.
-...in very Catherine fashion,
was like, "Annie, come on
and meet Jimmy."
And so I kind of Gollumed
out of the green room
and approached you.
-Gollum.
-And you were like, "Annie
it's so great to meet you.
You do such a great job
on the show."
And my -- all of my internal
organs fell out of me and then
like, just vowels and consonants
spilled out of my mouth
and then I ran, not walked
back to the green room.
You were still standing there.
[ Laughter ]
Ran back to the green room
and promptly burst into tears.
[ Audience awws ]
-Oh, my gosh.
-And then I was recounting
this story to my parents,
and my father has never been
more disappointed in me.
[ Laughter ]
And he was like,
"Kid, for Jimmy Fallon?"
-Yes!
-"You cried for Jimmy Fallon?"
-"Yes, Dad!" That's right!
-And so I have to be on
my best -- no tears tonight.
-No, come on.
-No. Don't do it.
-Get over here.
Come on, get over here.
-No!
-Come on, get over here.
Look at you, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Come on. Look at you.
Come on, no tears,
no tears, Dad!
No tears, Dad! No tears, Dad
-No tears, Dad!
-Ah, I love that story.
Dad, you're right.
Yeah, you can't cry here, man.
We love you too much.
-So disappointed.
-But that's so funny. Come on.
Then we had you on
and we have to do this reall
for when we talk about the show.
We have to say --
We have to show it and say
you're on the show
"Schitt's Creek."
[ Cheers and applause ]
But we have to show this
legally.
"Ew, David," became a catchprase
of yours.
Do people just scream that
at you now, which is odd?
-Yes.
-Ew?
-And I just found out
recently -- some woman told us
that I only actually say,
"Ew, David"
twice in the entire series
[ Laughter ]
-No.
-Yes.
But I also said like, "Ugh
David" or like, "Why, David?
-Yes, yes, you said it!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I tacked "David" on to
whatever I possibly could.
And it just kind of
spiraled out of --
this "ew, David" thing
spiraled out of control.
-You're phenomenal.
I mean, people are just doin
impressions of you
and you're just -- yeah.
You hit a home run.
I want to talk
about your new show
because I can't actually say
that on TV either.
-Yeah, I'm so sorry.
-But this is a great show.
"Kevin Can Blank Himself."
"F... Himself." It is a sitcom
It's very funny,
but it's also a drama.
-Yes.
-How do you set this up?
-It's a tricky one.
-Uh-huh.
-Okay, so you know the sitco
husband that we've come to know,
the kind of schlubby, beer
drinking, sports-loving doofus
-Absolutely, yes.
-It's not about him.
It's about his wife.
And we follow her
into this secret life
that she leads
when she's not around him.
And we find out
that she's very angry
and very frustrated
and really needs a change.
And that change
may or may not lead to
a murder plot
against her husband.
[ Laughter ]
-Do you guys want fun?
This is fun.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I mean, what do you want, right?
I want to show everyone a clip
Here's the great Annie Murph
in "Kevin Can F... Himself."
Take a look at this.
-Game over!
It's stinkin' lap time, Neil
Hey, babe?
-Yes.
-Can you grab us freshies?
-Oh!
-Allison.
Avert your eyes.
I can't have you leaving Kevin
for me.
♪♪♪♪
-I'm fine!
-Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's cool.
-It's cool.
-That's different. I love it
Annie Murphy.
"Kevin Can F... Himself"
airs Sundays at 9:00 p.m. on AMC
and is streaming on AMC+.
Thank you so much
for coming back to the show.